[Music]
Agriculture on the move. Agriculture.
Agriculture on the move.
[Music]
Agricult St. Lucia. Welcome to the
program Agriculture on the Move. My name
Philip Sydney your host. Today we
discussing rodents in or rodent control
in
agriculture simply means rats affecting
our crops simply as it is. But to my
right is Mr. Christopher Luben who is
the owner and managing director of FDL
um pest control solutions. And of course
next to him is Mr. Alexander was the
crop protection officer attached to the
Ministry of Agriculture. Gentlemen,
welcome to the program. Thank you. Thank
you. Chris Bayer, of course, you know,
you're not new to this this this um area
here. Um but let us St. Lucian Lu who is
Chris Lubin? Give us a little
background. Okay. I am Christopher
Lubin, an aronomist by profession. I
started working in the agricultural
sector at Windban in 1985 where I worked
with the plant pathologist and
subsequently with both the plant
pathologist and nematologist. My work
involve working in with pesticides,
neatocides, fungicides in controlling
cigar disease and also nematodes
um and other pests in bananas. And I was
lucky to whilst working at Windland for
10 years go off to do my first degree at
the University of the West Indies where
I studied aronomy of course and because
of my performance I got an opportunity
to start an
MIL/PhD with a European funded um
project. However, I lost all my research
to tropical storm Debbie right and the
funds went run out. So I basically moved
on where I worked with ran pollen which
is now beer crop science where I worked
as a an individual who developed
pesticides between Latin America and the
Caribbean farm with that company and
subsequently Renick Incorporated which
is a company that was based in Puerto
Rico where I worked as a product
development and marketing manager and
after that I came like back to St. Mucha
and I formed FDL pest control solutions
because I worked with companies across
the Caribbean, Latin America in pest
management. Working out of Puerto Rico,
I worked both with agriculture, public
health, urban pest management and had
done a fair amount of work. So I went
off to study pest management both US and
Europe and I I've kept up in in touch
with that and I've done a fair amount of
work with dicide companies and other
pest management of um manufacturers of
pesticides based on my research
background to develop them in the
region. Okay.
Well, a wealth of
knowledge. Of course, Clus, I mean,
everybody knows Clus has been with us in
the ministry for a while. Of course,
right now, I think it's Dr. Alexander
now. PhD.
Um, rodents have been around for many,
many, many moons. Um, we know the effect
it has on, um, crops as far as farmers
are concerned. uh it from an economic
standpoint it has set them back a lot.
um we have tried rod dentisticides over
the years and um with the rest are still
around you know so tell us what's what's
happening now I'm I'm hearing new things
are happening in your collaboration with
with Chris so give us a little
background as you said rodents they they
have been in for a while but in in terms
of agricultural production they cause
between estimated that between 2 to 10%
of some crops
is lost due to
rodents. Again, they are major vectors
for some zunotic diseases. Mhm. Rudent,
they can affect the
crop before harvesting and they can
affect the crop after harvesting.
They can at planting they can go and
they can eat the seeds that that you you
you planted and they can cause a lot of
problems in terms of the the post-h
harvest. Um it has been an issue in
terms of the the agriculture production
in India.
Basically the farmers have depended a
lot on
neaticides
but yes you have had some level of
control but you need some thing that is
more
sustainable on a yearly basis thousands
of dollars of neatides are imported into
the
country and based on that are you seeing
that if you have to um do some research
in terms of the amount that is imported
and control of the pest. Is it warrant
further investment in the maticide? Is
there a dire need for transition to
something that is more environmentally
friendly? Because again, you will use
the rodenticide and it can basically
contaminate the crop as well. Mhm. Also,
you you'll kill the some of the rats out
in the field and they can again that can
be an issue for for in terms of the
safety of the of the crop. So hence the
reason for us now doing some trial in
terms of something that is more
environmentally friendly something some
fertility control for rodents basically
something like a contraceptive in human
being where you try and control the the
the fertility of the of the of the male
and the female so that you can have an
impact in terms of the of the population
but there are limitations in terms of
the um the the use of the fertility
products. It has to be sustained because
once you stop it means the the
the get back fertile again. So multiply
faster. Mr. Lubin and I we collaborated
on some research in the Roso area. So I
think he is quite vers in the area and
he's going to expound more on what we
did that day during this trial. Mhm.
Well going back to Rosa was nostalgic.
That's why I started off as you're home.
You're home. Yes. Um but I worked with
uh with two um rodenticide producing
companies. One with the fertility
product and one with an anticoagulant.
But I want to start by saying we should
try to change from speaking about rodent
control to rodent pest management. Yes.
Management because if we think like that
it we need to understand the biology of
the rat and its food preferences and
also the way the pesticide or the
rodenticide works. So we looked at the
the birth control product. We looked at
an acute poison and we also looked at
two what we call anticoagulant um
rodenticide. And if I can just go into
that a little bit. Yes, definitely.
Rodents scent taste is very important to
rats. Rats are omnivores like us. All
right. And there's um silanthropic which
means that they benefit like
cockroaches, ants and other insects.
they benefit from man in the sense that
what we eat they eat and what we do they
know they they take advantage of it. So
the two most important factors would be
in the case of a farmer I'd say the most
important factor is sanitation because
when you go on farms there's some
indiscriminate use of food. That's one
but also that what they're growing is
food. Yes. And if a rat is raised in
that area eating a particular kind of
food from its mother's womb it's very
conscious of what to eat. And rats now
smell each other's mouth. Okay.
Um um carbon dulfide is a is a smell
that comes out of rats out of rat's
mouth or rodent's mouth and that's very
important to the young. Yes. Okay. They
smell. Yes. They smell and they they're
very good at using that to eat because
although they're omnivores they're risk
outside there. So rats if they eat the
wrong thing they'll die. So they've
learned to use cues. And um there are
three things that we can look at. One I
mentioned it's that they look at the
others. Another one is picker. They if
they're if they eat food and um they're
not too sure. Pika is practiced by some
mammals. They eat dirt and the clean it
would help it stick and get get out. But
then because rats cannot vomit, okay?
They can't vomit. They have a very
strong the the valve between the stomach
and the esophagus is is strong. So
unlike us who use our diaphragm
individually, the two muscles and we can
force this open, rats can't do that. So
because of that, they would have to
find a way to survive and making sure
they understand food based on taste,
smell is very important and also
urine. Rats pee a lot on different
things. So in the case of female,
estrogen, progesterone is important. The
female rat which is who's about to go
into heat would pee everywhere for the
the stronger male to come, right? So
they do it. Some in some cases the
younger rats that not even there yet
would pee on the stronger meal. So
therefore they remember who to go by who
to go by you know so it's it's signs
that have already been said it right. So
when we looked at the area, farmers were
complaining about sweet potatoes, corn,
melons, pumpkin as well and pumpkin. So
the intention was to look at
palletability.
How would the rats react to this? So if
I go back based on our age in this room
here, if we go back, farmers before use
a product called phospho in cocoa. And
what they were doing was creating what's
called bait shininess. the rat ate it,
some would die, some wouldn't die, but
those that didn't die would remember
what they ate and would not eat it for
at least 3 months. So that that concept
was very interesting to me in terms of
trying to look at the crop because the
farmers are saying, "Okay, I'm buying
how much rodenticide like it too and I'm
still seeing the thing." So what I found
out
was a lot of them use pellets and
pellets are designed for indoor use, not
outdoor use. As experts, we know how to
use it in the field, but the farmer
doesn't. So he was basically throwing
money away. Mhm. And then we looked at
the liquid which is not for general use.
So what we did was first put out the
pest the rodenticides where we we
tainted food with liquid rodenticide. We
used the normal rodenticide but the two
of them one had more wax than the other.
And when we got two things we got uptake
with the rodenticide and we got bit
shyness with the food. We then put the
the palatable then we put the um the
sausage base which is the um the birth
control and we got very good uptake on
it. Now it's a long-term trial. The key
here was to see palletability. The
farmers were very pleased because they
saw the uptake and we were able to prove
that we can prevent a rat from eating
watermelon. Okay. Like the old people
would say they would think that you know
watermelon you know and they wouldn't
eat it. We were able to prevent them
from eating pumpkin um pumpkin and eat
what we wanted them to eat and the was
great. How based on that? I mean um in
in layman's term, how can that happen?
That's a good point. In layman's terms,
a farmer should not just think of I'm
growing a crop so I can sell and make
money. He has to think of it and I said
pest management. Okay. So we have two
kinds of rats in St. Lucia. the roof rat
seems to be the one that's affecting
them the most because they would say to
me we saw them pass on the branches of
the you know the trees or on the fronts
of the coconut trees and we can see them
moving. So let's go backwards before
people use that metal strip on coconut
trees. That's one that's one factor
that's very important, right? Even the
trees if they have to. Two is know which
rat and we can tell it by looking at the
the droppings of the rat and also if we
see them because the roof rat has a much
longer tail, bigger airs. It's a
slender. It's a nicer looking rat
compared to the Norway rat which we see
all around the place. Right? So it's
important to know which rat is
affecting. So the rats in cast is these
are the Norway rats. In 2004, we did
some work there. Some work. It was very
interesting. They're all over. But these
are the nori rats which are bulkier,
stockier, heavier, and they they tend
both rats don't always agree, but we've
seen places where they coexist. Okay.
Okay. Um so the important thing here is
to the farmer needs to understand if I'm
going to grow
potatoes, I can impact the rat before I
start my crop. Okay? Not when the crop
is growing because the rats are there.
And like when farmers when they remember
I spoke about sanitation when they leave
whatever in the field there's stuff
there you need to clean that out but
also they can use it to prevent rats
from eating their crop. Okay. And to
Clintus's point the the birth control
can come in after because it's a
long-term strategy. So you can keep that
population of rodents down and you now
need to look at the other thing that was
interesting is we use rodent bait
stations and it's a monitoring device.
So I can always come and say okay yes
they took it because farmers generally
buy the rodenticide and throw them out
and the the rodenticide disappears but
does not mean they're out. So with the
unit we have we can actually see that
they n on it and we keep on replacing.
So rodent pest management if I put bait
and I come back and there's no bait
left. I did not put enough. Okay. I must
always come back and see some bait left
because if if that means the rats came
in they hit everything and they went
away. Now a farmer is always on his
field so he can be trained okay to do
that right but I'm happy with what I saw
and a lot more work has to be done but
we can from what I'm seeing and with
some of the people that have interacted
with us um farmers can be trained
to understand their field and understand
what to do to reduce damage. So what
happens to a farmer next door who does
not um carry up that control? Um will it
affect come back and affect the the the
the stations where you bitted in that
particular farmer? Say farmer number one
you're working but farmer number two
doesn't do anything. what happens
remember again what he is saying is very
important with the the the the control
whereby if there's an urgent situation
in humans the use of the toxic pesticide
is important because you'll knock down
the population but with the the
fertility um control now what you'll
have is that um yes they'll be sterile
but they're going to leave as well you
depending on natural mortality to bring
down the population so with with the
neatide it will much quicker than And
and what you have you may have is that
um even if you control the population on
some of the farms that you conducting
the recession you'll have immigrants
those neighboring areas you'll have the
farm since there's a void now they will
come into the area where trip and then
they will get the population will hence
the reason why you need um continuous
baiting with the the fertility so that
they can because not only the the
parents that you looking at fertility
for looking at all the offsprings as
well. So fertility will be continuous.
And remember I indicated that they have
a food preference, right? So if you put
the two things together, you're
basically saying I'm trying to get them
to not want to eat food in this farm,
but it doesn't mean that others would
not eat from the other farm. So there is
need for that structure in terms of the
how it should be done. And it comes back
to research. We we in the windband days
a lot of research was done in bananas,
but a lot of work is done now, but
there's no set research in these areas.
And I think um farmers can be trained
because the farmers we work with were
initially a bit skeptical but when they
saw the results they were yes it's gone
and we will actually be able to prevent
rash from eating corn prevent them from
eating and go for the watermelon yeah
and go for the the birth control and
it's a it looks like sausage so I guess
it's something that's palatable enough
for them and rats initially don't if
there's something new they don't eat it
up front remember I said they so they
would taste
And if they now realize, oh shucks, this
thing got me sick, they will leave
messages for others not to eat it. And
so it's important in that case they at
all. They ate all of it. So it's
palatable. So there is some interesting.
So how many farmers you worked with in
that? We worked with four farmers. One
corn, watermelons, pumpkin. We three
farmers. Three farmers. Three farmers.
Okay. But I know there is a lot of um
rats um when it comes to cocoa
production. So are you all hoping to
Well, if there are opportunities there,
yes, because it can rodents can be
controlled. Okay, we just need to take
time to understand it. So rodents, rats
don't see too well. People need to first
understand that don't see too well. Rats
feel. So they have special hairs on
their bodies called vibr, the the
whiskers. So a rat runs the whiskers
come for you never see a rat run into a
wall because it's aware of it it
surroundings and they will mark like I
said they will mark with their urine. So
if something was moved they would mark
it to know that was it wasn't there. So
they they work with that. So if it's a
roof rat we first have to establish
whether it's a roof rat or whether it's
now a rats affecting them. Okay. And if
it's now a rats they borrowing the wrong
roof rats are in the trees and they
leave because they don't see too well
and they rub they leave those rub marks.
So the sebaceious glands what we'd call
ring around the collar they produce that
and they mark the areas they they go
through heavily. So we would see that
and we can train people to understand
what's fresh and what's stale. So it's
important to know the habits of the rat.
Again I come back to pest management not
pest control because if not you're doing
the same thing over and over expecting a
different result and it's not going to
happen. Okay. There's there's of course
we know about the rat urine and
leptospiryosis. Yes. Okay. Um how can
that be controlled in terms of um would
you think there'll be less
leptospirrosis using that method down
the road with less rats around? I would
say in the farming areas you'd have less
rodents and less chance of that
happening. Okay. Okay. So the key thing
is monitoring systems and a rodent bit
station makes a difference. Not throwing
the bit around because in a farm it's
out it's in the open. The rodenticide is
not going to last forever. Right. So
it's important to put it in an area. If
we find the runway of the rat, you don't
put stuff in the runway because they
know that wasn't there. So you have to
now trick them into finding it. Okay? So
you have to look at home and food and
remember they have a preference already.
So what you put in, you just add into
the menu, right? So it's important to
understand how So you have to understand
the the the mo of the rat. Yes. Exactly.
You have to think that. But we seem to
be um focusing a lot on rats but mice as
well. Oh yes. So it's rat and and and
the mice. The mice. Yeah. So for us it
is very important creating what is
called the bit shyness because if you
have a watermelon crop you should not
wait when this the the the rats start
eating your watermelon. That's for
control the baiting. But what you can do
is if you know your watermelon will be
ready for probably in a couple of weeks.
What you can do is try and you can
purchase a watermelon put the watermelon
in the bit station apply the the the the
liquid neaticide and the bit
sh and and tell the others that I ate
this thing in the farm and then I I you
send the population I'm going to die and
so on. So definitely that is very
important creating the bit shyness
whereby the the the if you have pumpkin
as well with the pumpkin farmer in the
base station we put the pumpkin under
liquid neatide
rodent keep saying not neatide sorry the
rodenticide so um it's it was very
interesting to um again the farmers they
were very receptive to um the the
research and we're looking to um
probably scale up if you can get other
regions where um we can transfer the
technologies to the other regions where
um crops have been cultivated that how
how long this thing has you all did this
I did it for 3 weeks we did it for 3
weeks just to understand the
palatability but also in do in that time
we inspected we were on the farms at
least twice a week okay sometimes every
other day we just wanted to make sure
that like I I mentioned earlier if we
put rodent um um rodenticide in the bait
station it should not run out so we had
to go as frequently as we possibly could
Um farmers also have to be trained. You
have your farm, your shed, the way you
eat and what you do inside is important.
Okay. So that's the sanitation part
again you know. So there's a it's not
just one thing. Mhm. Okay. We can put
rodenticide till we get blue in the
face. If we don't understand the why we
fail. So the food is what we want to
protect. Mhm. You create big shininess,
you use the product, you you know you
reduce the population. And
um it's not only in rodents you now have
this this happening. And it happens with
birds, you know, there are there are
things that can be used. So it's it's a
a range of activities that should be
done on a farm and the farmer has to pay
attention to it because if not, he will
always have issues, right? And he can be
trained to see the runways of the rat to
look at where they come from and they
know it, they see it. It's just to
understand how to use what they have to
to control. So Okay. So you all worked
in Roso? Yes. Okay. So where else will
that be replicated? Um we're looking at
um region five that's in the V4 area.
Also we we did it on um the
watermelons, the pumpkins and the corn
farmer. Very important to us will be um
the having a trial with a a sweet potato
farmer. Yes. because we know um there's
a serious issue in terms of the rat
infestation in in sweet potatoes. So
once you can get a sweet potato farmer
who is interested, we can transfer the
technology to whatever region that um we
feel that um we can have the the trial
on. What was interesting to me is the
potato farmer said to you there is you
know there there's still potatoes in the
field after harvest. M so it might be
small potatoes or pieces they left in
the field and that's a source of food
some of them might might start to grow
because they then till the land because
we actually went back when that process
started so we didn't just come and we
went back to look at it so the lands
were being prepared so that's when you
now would disturb the potatoes right but
in some cases if you look at it from a
practical perspective some of them might
already be growing and now you're
digging it up and remember rodents you
smell
So if they sense that they can be coming
back from that early and then you plant
your crop and they now know hey I have a
source of food. So it's important that
habits change some of the practices have
to be adjusted and we can have good
success. Okay. So at what point will um
that road denticide be available to the
public for at for purchasers? I'm I'm
sure. Yeah. But I I this is something
that the ministry would have to to
decide. We can't, we wouldn't because
it's something that requires proper
training to use. Okay. Um it's dangerous
stuff. You know, no pesticide is safe
and you want to make sure it's used the
right way. And I say that simply because
over the years what we've learned is
farmers or people use different products
as rodenticides. Furodan, for example,
was one of the main ones that was used
for years. and farmers mix stuff even
down to using the cans where they they
cook it and then you know they they they
tint the food. So I think it's important
for people to understand the why the how
what you do and it's important to to
document it. That way people are aware
and the training is is taken seriously.
If not we will start something and then
if it's not done properly people will
see that as a failure. Okay. And we need
to make sure people understand what's
being done why it's being done. Okay.
So, so there there have to be that
collaborative uh situation with the
ministry of agriculture to ensure that
it works. So, yeah. You mentioned you
said when would the the
neatide sorry be available on the
market? Firstly, it has to be evaluated
by the pesticide and the chemical
control board because if a new product
is coming into the country, we'll need
to do the necessary risk assessments to
mitigate some of the impacts of the of
the product. So once this is done um the
product can be taken to the board for
registration.
Okay. So so in so right now it's it's
just a trial tested trials around the
island and like I said again so um you
do have any a specific time frame before
it gets gets the to the board for
approval. Um it's difficult to put a
time frame because um if an a registrant
um submit a dossier it means well after
reviewing this particular dossier you
may ask for further information. Mhm.
Where was it tested? Where was it tested
while going for the dosi may see um
something where you see some impact some
hazard on on on the um dossi. will the
registrant will need to prove to you
that some of the persons or where where
it was some of the risks that he's is
presented where it was mitigated some of
the research papers that was done on
this particular product. So all these
the important pieces of
information they're very important in
terms of the registration of the product
to mitigate the risks associated with
the product. M so so you still so
there's no time frame you cannot but but
still there is opportunity to train
farmers until that time to understand
what they should and shouldn't do great
because it's it's it's not going to
happen overnight but um my observations
because in our industry we are
observational biologists my observations
are people want a quick fix but you're
dealing with a pest that has been around
for a very long Mhm. And being silent
anthropic, it's adjusted its lifestyle
to us. So we need to readjust and it
will not happen with just a pesticide.
It has to happen with
an attitude change towards understanding
I have my crop. I want to make sure I
save I have maximum yield and less
damage. What do I need to do? And years
ago we've been training with farmers
where for example using fogging um
misting sorry for secret to control
things like that you have to train
people need to understand wind direction
in that case how to move through the
crop it's no different in this case it's
it's to understand how I should use a
rodenticide and if I understand that and
I see the results I believe if I don't
see the results then of course to
continue I don't yes
again what's very important for us is
um the farmers they've been really
reliant on pesticide use and the use of
pesticide is not the only means of
controlling rodents. M so um there are
other technologies available for
controlling like the what we trying
presently the fertility control the use
of carbon monoxide and probably the um
blocking of the borrows and so there are
lots of other measures available but
specifically we feel that um the use of
the fertility product is going to again
the product is an organic product. No,
that's another thing right in terms of
environmental protection and food
safety. It will help in that regard.
Finally, sir, me I hope it it catches
on. I love research. That's what I
always um as professionally that's where
I was I my profession started. And I
think um urban pest management, pest
management in agriculture, it's very
important to understand the why and the
how. Um we should not just be applying
stuff for applying it sake. And I think
it's important for all involved to to
take it seriously before an end result.
I think for me it's um that's the food
security. Great. The Ministry of
Agriculture, we've been talking about
food security for a very long time. And
if you are able to control um the the
the rodents in watermelons, in the
cantaloupes, in the pumpkins, in in
sweet potato, there can be at least a
10% increase in those crops. Definitely
which can benefit more money more.
Gentlemen, thank you for being here.
I wish you all success and um I'm sure
that um once you all are on track with
what you do, we will get there. Thank
you again. Thank you.
You've been watching Agriculture on the
Move. We want to thank you for viewing
the program. We always want to tell you
remember agriculture is our business and
we need to eat fresh St. Lucia's best
cuz once you can control the rodents
obviously we'll have an increase in
production. Thank you again for viewing.
I'm Philip City saying goodbye. I'll see
you again.
Agriculture on the move. Agriculture
movement. Agriculture on the move.
Agriculture on the move.
Agriculture on the move. Agriculture
move. Agriculture on the move. I recall
on my mom.
[Music]